for women to accept the truth about
themselves
[Music]
it tells us
it's from a young age
treated like a queen from a guy yeah why
do you deserve that
you're just a regular you're like a five
that's amazing yeah if you're an eight
maybe
you're like a five six like why do you
think you deserve princess treatment and
then and you're and you're not a virgin
okay you want to be courted like one
yeah okay
um that is so true
but what I don't understand men are
afraid to tell them to and women don't
want to hear the truth what do they want
women they don't even know we don't know
um
I've been wanting the top 10 percent of
men
who like them
and so to cater to them yeah yeah so
they want the it's like when they say I
like I like a nice guy they're talking
about that guy that's like kind of like
he's not nice and they like him and
they're like well if he'd be a little
nicer to me like that's what they're
talking about they're not talking about
you Brad like
dude you work at McDonald's like she's
not you can you could be a little bit
meaner yeah yeah sure yeah what type of
man do you do you date a lot do I date a
lot yeah I mean I date you date yeah and
what do you look for in when you're
dating what what type of man man you
date
um
I like guys that I I can't date liberals
I can't do it yeah yeah
um I mean I like guys that have
leadership qualities
um and I would say it's conservative and
have similar like values I would say
you um you seem so confident a man of
intimidated around you
no they're not afraid of you I don't I
don't think about it I think that's just
an excuse like women say when like men
don't like them right they're like oh
they're intimidated by me no no you're
just yeah
an average guy can beat you up I promise
he's not intimidated by you but it seems
as though the average guy is afraid to
just be himself around a woman
[Music]
like he can put on a a front instead of
just being himself
you know here at one way around guys
you'll be himself say what he wants
whatever but when he with a woman he put
on
most of the time not on at all but like
a nice personality in order to get the
woman to like him oh yeah because they
try to like be what women want but it's
not what they want right so yeah I would
say that happens amazing yeah it's kind
of like on my show it's funny because
sometimes guys will say things to me and
I'll be like more like feministy and
they think that I'll like it because
they don't know me you know it's like
yeah I'm like oh stop it I gotta go stop
it you would tell them that or you just
said to yourself
uh it depends where am I at it depends
how
like if I go on a date and it's the
beginning of the day
I'll probably just ride this thing out
like I'll probably just be quiet and
never yeah right on a date speaking of
dating you should demand Pay of the
woman
the the man the man yeah and why is that
um
I I just think like most girls won't
respect you if you don't pay if you're
trying to split it but honestly like a
lot of girls you don't even have to take
on dates
I know she likes you enough she'll go on
a walk you know panty money
so you know you don't have to spend any
money How about if if the woman inviting
a man out to dinner should she paint in
um she should offer she should yeah I
think so yeah
um I don't really have strong opinions
on it well you know yeah where are you
when it comes to politics do you uh are
you more conservative in politics as
well yeah I'm like really conservative
oh yeah I probably like too much my dad
says I take things too far oh yeah yeah
are you more like your father or your
mother
when it comes to things like that oh
both but I would they're both pretty
conservative but I'd say my dad's
slightly more conservative and I'm even
more conservative than my dad oh really
yeah yeah nice yeah like my dad believes
in child support I'm like cut it cut it
none naisy nada yeah you made your bed
lie in it stop it that's right amazing
yeah so your father and mother would be
concerned how to influence on you as far
as politics yeah because if I take a
personality test it says I'm super left
actually like um the Jordan Peterson
like understand myself test or whatever
right it says like you have a 97 chance
of being liberal but luckily my dad
anytime I like started to go that way he
would just explain it to me right on so
yeah nice
who do you think of the Great White Hope
what's that Donald Trump
[Laughter]
my gosh I miss him I miss his tweets
yeah I yeah I mean
I don't have like I'm not like a
die-hard like Trump fan but I thought he
was a good president I thought
and I look at him as an Entertainer and
oh my God he was so funny he was so
funny do you agree with me and you know
how soon you know that that he was the
greatest president so far
um one of them I would say I don't know
enough about every single president yeah
I mean you know the one in my lifetime
right in my lifetime yeah
you know the father Messiah you know who
the father Messiah is right no Barack
Obama
are you calling the Fallen Messiah
and the reason for that because when he
first ran the black was like oh he's
sent by God he's sent by God and then
when he disappointed them all of a
sudden he fell you know now he used to
follow Messiah I was pretty young when
all that happened oh you were I think I
was in eighth grade when he got elected
so I wasn't really no one was calling
him the Messiah at my school but we were
in you know I was like 12 right so it
wasn't and so did you vote for the Great
White Hope
the I didn't vote the first time around
because I wasn't that like I didn't
really have a strong opinion either way
right second time around I did yeah oh
okay nice do you think he'll come back
again
kind of old
[Laughter]
like almost 80 Now isn't he
I think he's in he's like 73 74 75
somewhere in there
yeah I mean it's just like eight years
it's like or another four years yeah
yeah if if you know he's healthy and
stuff yeah if ever we I mean if ever we
needed him we need him now yeah yeah are
you surprised I call him to drink white
hope
I was not expecting that name
you never heard me say that before
so you are how do you feel when you're
attacked online by the feminists and
people like that
I think it's funny I think of them as
children actually
yeah oh you're thinking of feminine is
that yeah they're mostly whales that's
like the biggest one I get
yeah because there's a clip of me going
around where I say no one looks good at
300 pounds and then it's like all these
whales as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible